you probably recognize Rick Petko from
American Chopper he started working at
Orange County Choppers as a fabricator
and builder in July 2003 but he's not
part of the operation anymore
so what's Petco up to these days in 2012
Petco married Britney Cockrum on an
episode of American Chopper
even though senior and junior were
feuding at the time they still came out
for Petco's wedding once Petco was
married his priorities began to shift
Petco and Cockerham welcomed their first
daughter
Everly Rose in October 2013 judging by
the countless adorable photos of Everly
hanging out on motorcycles on Petco's
Instagram profile it's clear that he's
loving fatherhood and encouraging his
daughter to follow in his footsteps
Everly seems to be taking after her
father and looking up to his example
according to Petco this girl already
understands the need for speed Petco
told Discovery Channel if it's got
wheels she says go
[Music]
I feel the need
after American Chopper was canceled in
2012
OCC wasn't quite done being featured on
reality TV a spinoff at the popular
series simply titled Orange County
Choppers aired on CMT from 2013 through
2014 and Petco continued on as a cast
member Orange County Choppers filled the
void for dedicated fans of American
Chopper but the series was short-lived
running for just one season it was a
similar concept to American Chopper but
just didn't carry the same appeal it
wasn't quite the same without senior and
juniors fights keeping things
interesting it was nice for fans who
weren't quite ready to say goodbye to
senior Petco and the rest of the crew
but it was missing the exciting dynamics
between cast members that made the
original so entertaining
after Orange County Choppers ended some
of the American Chopper cast members
reunited in 2014 for a Discovery Channel
special titled American Chopper Shack
bike unfortunately not everyone was back
on board for Petco made an appearance
but there was no sign of junior the
special was about the crew building a
custom bike for Shaquille O'Neal and
while it was a challenge the crew really
stepped up Shaq's custom-made bike
nicknamed the Man of Steel turned out to
be the biggest in OCC history this bike
featured a 48 edged handlebar a six-inch
rake a 23 inch front wheel and a 20 inch
rear wheel until the American Chopper
revival started airing this was the last
time viewers saw the crew at OCC appear
together on screen in following years
Petco made some pretty serious changes
in his life and career they would take
him down a new path to diverge from the
rest of the cast and crew from American
Chopper plenty of people can relate to
Petco's frustration with his long
commute which he put up with for years
while working at OCC three hours in the
car each day took away from time spent
with his family enjoying hobbies or
simply relaxing fans of American Chopper
were well aware of Petco's extended
traveling times says he mentioned it
plenty of times on the show and although
he pushed through it for over a decade
it clearly began to wear him down you
know rich one of those guys he doesn't
really say a lot but every day he drives
the OCC about to
hours each way from Pennsylvania one
reason that Petco left OCC was because
he wanted to spend less time in the car
and more time closer to home doing what
he really loved and engaging with his
local community it also made life a lot
easier for his family once American
Chopper ended and Petco became dad he
began to think seriously about working
closer to home this was always part of
his plan even though it took several
years for him to jump ship from OCC in
2016 Petco opened his own fabrication
shop in Stroudsburg Pennsylvania in
conjunction with the Pocono Mountains
our Lee Davidson dealership it all
started in December 2015 when Petco
entered a partnership with the
dealerships management according to
Petco they were super enthusiastic about
working together from the moment that he
approached them which took him by
surprise it's rare for American
dealerships to include fabrication work
in their shops knowing him personally is
a hard worker and a stand-up guy the
dealership managers knew that bringing
Petco into the business would be a huge
boost now customers can essentially
build their custom dream bikes through
the dealership and Petco's partnership
generated publicity Petco is clearly
happy with this new full-time gig and
the responsibilities that it presents
Petco tell the Pocono Record it has
really anything we need to make anything
for anyone's Harley if they can dream it
up we can build it that's the main goal
peco's talents are not limited to
working on bikes he has plenty of other
interests and now that he's not working
full-time for OCC he has more time to
spend on outside pursuits Petco shop our
PD and company runs out of his home
through his shop Petco does metalwork
hand forging and custom knife work as
Petco explains on his personal website
he was originally interested in metal
work long before going on TV
yes his true passion is building
motorcycles that's not all he loves to
do he actually went to Welding school
eventually he went to work as an
industrial contractor realigning kilns
and furnaces for a living now his
business specializes in handmade
culinary knives and he takes custom
orders he often shares his recent knife
work that he's proud of an Instagram
[Music]
lady when
when this whole situation - you're
almost like a training guys be training
peco's latest project is creating custom
wedding bands for RPG and company
customers wedding bands are the perfect
opportunity for him to get creative with
his metal work Petco only takes custom
orders for wedding bands working with
customers to create a band that is a
symbol of their luck there is no doubt
that it would cost a little extra to
hire Petco for a custom wedding band but
for big fans of American shopper who
like his artistic style it might be
worth the price after all a wedding band
is meant to last for life Petco and
Cocker rooms second child Lucy was born
in 2016 like her older sister Everly she
seems to love hanging out in the bike
shop and spending time with her dad
Petco supports his daughters by
encouraging him in one of their favorite
sports Taekwondo Petco is enthusiastic
about fatherhood and putting his family
first viewers of American Chopper will
remember that he was always one of the
most down-to-earth members of the cast
he kept his head down focused on his
work and prioritized what really
mattered it's likely that his new
responsibilities as a father were one of
the reasons he keeps a lower profile
these days spending time with his wife
and daughters is clearly number one on
his list and being a reality TV star
isn't always conducive to being a family
man Petco is a relatively private person
anyone who watched American Chopper will
know that he was never in it for the
fame and fortune he was just along for
the ride and he was never too attached
to the idea of becoming a bona fide
reality TV star he does his job for the
love of it as evidenced by the fact that
he is continued in the same line of work
even after the cameras stopped rolling
he shows no signs of stopping the very
qualities that made Petco so endearing
to audiences like his laid-back
low-maintenance attitude in comparison
to other reality TV stars is probably
why he's not vying to be in front of the
camera anymore he doesn't crave the
attention he's had a pretty good run on
the small screen and now he's happy to
turn over a new leaf and seek out
different opportunities
HECO toed the pocono record of his time
on American Chopper that was great while
it lasted but it still wasn't the core
of
what I was about or what I like to do
even so Petco appeared on the web series
sons of speed for the Motor Trend
Network in 2017 the series followed
Billy Laine who also builds motorcycles
and his good friend Xavier Murray and
their quest to revive the era of bored
track racing Lane is an avid collector
of motorcycle engines built in the early
20th century and his goal is to restore
them and bring them back to the
racetrack in sons of speed Lane and
Murray were preparing for an upcoming
race at the new spear in a Speedway in
Florida it's a limited series of only
two episodes so fans of American Chopper
looking for similar shows can easily
finish watching it in one night Peck
tows part in the show involved working
on a specific bike for Lane he was
interested in the project because it
meant that he would get to work with
older bikes which has always been one of
his passions Petco said I've always had
a thing for older bikes it's like a
resurgence it seems like with a lot of
people just wanting to bring back these
buttons to go 100 miles per hour on a
hundred-year-old bike is kind of cool
the mini series was a relatively low-key
commitment which is probably another
reason why Petco chose to partake after
being off the air for several years
American Chopper returned to the
Discovery Channel with a brand new
season in 2018 a full decade after their
business partnership crumbled senior and
junior were running their own shops but
they were finally ready to set aside
their differences and work together
on-camera again the biggest issue that
me and Paulie had was working together
so working on this Yankee bike is a
little strange it kind of brings back
some bad memories longtime fans were
definitely excited to see many of their
old favorite cast members
but not everyone returned for the
revival Petco was notably missing from
two most recent seasons and while
there's always a chance that he could
make a surprise appearance he hasn't
hinted at it and it seems unlikely he's
got a lot on his plate right now and it
seems like he would rather just keep the
door closed at American Chopper Petco's
fans will always be able to check in on
him and see what he's been working on
but when he said that reality TV was not
his major objective he meant it will
never sing never it's not unthinkable
the petcoke pay a visit to his friends
at OCC one day while the cameras are
rolling but for now it's safe to say
that American Chopper is behind him
Petco may not be on TV anymore
but fans who want to see what he's up to
could easily catch him on Instagram he
is very open about his latest projects
and updates
family life while he's clearly very
involved with his own community in
Stroudsburg he also has plenty of work
commitments all around the country Petco
travels for bike shows and races and
when possible
he likes to bring his family along with
him for example in October 2018 he
shared that he was traveling down to the
Tennessee motorcycle revival to show his
Indian racer in the blings cycles bike
show and ride the bike in the Flathead
race
Petco is also shared that he's looking
forward to participating in the sons of
Speed event again he's always updating
his fans on new bikes that he's working
on and whether or not he'll be getting
them out on the track
he knows that although his audience
can't tune in to see him on TV anymore
they are still interested in the bikes
he's constructing and where he's headed
next check out one of our newest videos
right here Plus even more looper videos
about your favorite shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]